well the u.s is reportedly planning to
withdraw
all american troops from afghanistan by
september 11th of this year
president biden is due to announce the
plans later on wednesday
there are about 3 000 american soldiers
in afghanistan serving alongside
some seven thousand additional nato
forces
biden's plan extends the may first
withdrawal deadline set by the trump
administration
by four months u.s officials say that'll
give washington more time to
coordinate an orderly withdrawal with
nato allies
but the taliban has threatened to renew
attacks if foreign forces
are not out by may
for more on this let's bring in dw's
bound regert who has the view from
brussels band uh this withdrawal it
would mark the end of 20 years of war in
afghanistan for the americans
how has that gone down with washington's
nato allies who rely
on the u.s for its true presence in
afghanistan
at least there's a sense of relief that
there is now
a plan for an orderly withdrawal the
trump administration wanted to leave
afghanistan already
on the 1st of may that would not have
been workable and feasible and so nato
can now plan for
four more months and the
ministers of defense and the foreign
secretaries of nato will gather later in
the day in a video conference to talk
about how
to organize this withdrawal because you
have to keep in mind that there are
9 000 troops in afghanistan 2 500 from
the americans but
seven thousands from at least 35
other nations and germany the second
biggest
supplier of troops in afghanistan so all
this has to be organized now
because the main goal of nato is of
course to get the troops out
safely the taliban in afghanistan
already threatened that they will attack
troops after may 1st so this will be a
very
difficult operation to leave afghanistan
after 20 years
and they're threatening to attack those
troops after may first because that is
the date that the trump administration
agreed to with the taliban
um for the u.s withdrawal um you know
given
that they're now talking about september
bound first of all what does this mean
for the future of peace talks with the
taliban and second of all
what does it mean for the stability of
the government in afghanistan what sort
of situation
could could the u.s be leaving behind
well a spokesperson for the taliban
already announced that
they would not take part in the next
round of so-called
peace talks for afghanistan which were
scheduled by turkey
at the end of this month um and the
taliban
the level of violence is is still high
in afghanistan it's
targeting the civil population the
civilians
and now um the taliban also threatened
to attack
the troops again so this will of course
destabilize the whole country
and after the troops have left it's
more or less sure that the taliban will
take over again and that we reach the
same status we had
20 years ago when nato went in okay
this potential withdrawal bound also
coming as nato is facing a threat much
closer to home as we know that's on the
russia-ukraine border
where moscow has been expanding its
military presence in recent weeks
it's drawn sharp rebukes from nato
members including the u.s
i just like to hear what the u.s
secretary of state has had to say on
this
and they get get your reaction
thereafter
the united states stands firmly uh
behind the uh
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine
and that's particularly important in a
time when we're seeing unfortunately
russia take a very provocative action
when it comes to ukraine we're now
seeing the largest concentration
of russian forces on ukraine's order
since
2014. diplomacy in high gear over
ukraine what's been happening baron
well the nato ministers will reassure
ukraine certainly today of their support
but they will not send any troops or
something to russia
and they all look now at washington
because president biden is inviting
the president of russia vladimir putin
for a summit
to solve all these issues you know the
relations are very bad
and nato is hoping that biden can
resolve the issues van riegert in
brussels thank you
you